you got spunk
well
i hate spawn
it was this fastest seven years i've
ever experienced in my life and it was
all happy
it put me on the map made my career
in 1970 ed landed the role of lou grant
mary tyler moore's hot-tempered boss he
had already been working in hollywood
for several years but bombed his first
audition for the show so he asked for
another shot
i have just been watching a man being
destroyed is it too late to send a film
crew
we we knew how good we were at the uh
because it was the best stuff i had ever
done or ever been identified with i
loved it and that's the magic of showbiz
you saved my life lou i saved my life
please ted i feel bad enough today
ed quickly became a household name
winning two golden globes and three
emmys i can remember winning the first
one
you know the wonder of winning an enemy
i never expected to get recognized
and then when i won the second year
i said this validates the first
we don't make the news sure we do
when the mary tyler moore show wrapped
in 1977 ed got his own spin-off lou
grant the drama nabbed him even more
awards so did roles in rich man poor man
and roots
they're telling us to sleep lightly mr
slater
ed had a passion for acting and with
more than 400 projects to his name his
career across generations your father
he's on the money list
in 2003 he played santa in the christmas
classic elk i read the script and i
couldn't wait to get my teeth in it i
just hope i did it justice
and in 2009 he was the voice of mr
frederickson in up
boys
i'm a grump
i'm not not as nice a grump he's more
patient than i am so they had to hold me
back
in recent years ed picked up guest roles
on shows like modern family you're a
snake you're a rat huh and cobra kai
you're eating bad meat boy you have not
slowed down do you plan on slowing down
anytime soon
death will take care of that
you are crazy
but who isn't he continued working into
his 90s and over the decades we were
with the tv icon
120 times the last interview was in
january following the passing of his
good friend and former co-star cloris
leachman what was the impression you got
of her the first time you met her
hold onto your hands folks
as huge as marvelous men like you don't
cry do they do
[Music]
you and mary tyler moore are tied for
the first seven acting emmys i think
only cloris is ahead of you guys oh god
she can go to hell
she's greedy broad
and while ed was known for his wit and
dry sense of humor the father of four
also had a serious side he was an
activist for health care immigration and
equal rights
the battle for equal representation on
the two
of minorities and of women
is still a failure a human rights
violation will be called for what it is
no matter where it comes from we're not
going to let it die
we will keep putting our own feet to the
fire and hope to affect change i'm very
pleased with what i've been able to do
in my life and what i got for it it's
been a blessed life
[Music]